all right time for another fun day on
the boat we are filming out our japanese
immigration forms uh because we need
that to get off the boat
i'm super tired i look at myself like
wow i am one tired person but i feel
okay nina woke me up five times last
night
through all her shenanigans so today
we're at sea
it's when we're hitting nagasaki so
there's a whole bunch of fun stuff
planned on the boat i don't remember
what it is but we'll look at the agenda
and go have some fun but first breakfast
i have
eggs with mushroom and cheese turkey
sausages chocolate
whatever that is
egg mcmuffin
watermelon and my fruit loops orange
juice and coffee what do you have
and chicken soup
and then egg with mushrooms oh man in
japan and noodles
and
and
hard-boiled
pear
so we finished breakfast came down did
some sudoku and
nina didn't finish hers and i'm still
struggling of mine this is supposed to
be easy level but uh no i think this is
more hard than anything
we're having a hard time maybe maybe
we're just not good at sudoku no i don't
think i made a mistake yet but i haven't
i haven't cracked it open yet uh but
next up we're gonna do
i'm gonna hold on to this
we're gonna do a paper airplane contest
where you have to create a paper
airplane
and then
make it fly
through this hoop
and so we gotta hopefully it flies
straight straight and through that hoop
so i'm gonna build one and uh
see how it goes
okay my paper airplane sucked it did not
go nina's is better so she's gonna enter
the competition
she has an airplane on her
shirt there so she should do well
quick early lunch i'm starting off with
a huge salad
broccoli cauliflower cheese
whole bunch of stuff and nina's up
getting her own and while i wait i'm
going to try to finish off my sudoku and
see if i can beat it
all right nina's turn
what are we eating
i have extra suits what kind of soup egg
drops egg drop soup okay and then
cabbage
and then
braised pork
and then i think this is this is curry
fish that looks good i'm not sure if
it's fish bar or meatball okay and then
this is um
i think i think it's beef brisket
this is nature
nina thinks it's pinocchio the
instructor
thinks it's uh olaf the snowman from
frozen
two final products
it was a almost all women class and they
were all making flowers and butterflies
and sunshines and rainbows
so
this is how amanda's quilling
this is manly quilling right here and i
have to sign the bottom left to make it
official so it's signed by the artist
nina by the sea's main quilling
okay next up is irish dancing part of my
heritage i'm i don't know what
percentage maybe a tenth irish something
like that but uh while we wait for the
irish engine class it's back to
sudoku see if i can master this thing
oh got a quick snack as we're waiting i
got a chocolate doughnut for me tiramisu
for nina
and tomato basil mozzarella sandwich
with oil and vinegar
but it looks like the class is going to
start so i gotta like scarf something
down quickly
and then dance
here comes nina
let's see it nina dance go go
one two three four five six seven back
step step back step step all right it's
formal night so we're all dressed up
got my
pink shirt on and dress pants and nina
looking
extra yummy in her
white dress behind we're gonna go take
some pictures
and then have some dinner so they're
doing portraits tonight and a lot of
them are on really uh what's the word
funky backgrounds you know there's the
one here of the guys on the boat it
looks so fake that we're not gonna do
that one but we found one where it's an
all black background and because of what
we're wearing tonight it's going to look
pretty good so we're going to line up
and take our pictures
i think we need to do a quick video
about how pretty nina is tonight in her
white dress
yummy
so we made our way down to the uh one of
the clubs
i was getting super nauseous
we're driving through a uh
edge of a tsunami or something here on
our way to japan
so we're on one of the top decks and i
had some bouncing bouncing bouncing
nina passed out fell asleep
and i uh i was getting nauseous so we
had to run down here at the waking up
let's take a ride down here uh i don't
know if we're gonna dance but it's uh
at least a little less bumpy here so
this is how we're closing that far
tonight
the wild house here
if you want the real goods i share my
best advice for entrepreneurs every week
in my newsletter click the link below to
check it out it's free
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun
inspiring and it's the only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period